-We have exactly 10 shows before
we go on Christmas break, which
means it's time for that beloved
"Tonight Show" tradition.
It's time for
"12 Days of Christmas Sweaters."
Here we go.
♪ -12 days of
Christmas sweaters ♪
♪ 10 days left ♪
-That's right.
Every show between now and
Christmas, we'll be giving
one lucky audience member
an outrageous Christmas sweater.
[ Cheers and applause ]
From the Countdown to Christmas
cabinet.
Now, since there are 10 shows
left, let's open door number 10.
Here we go.
-Well, actually, actually,
I thought, you know, before we
open it, that we actually
talk to the audience and see if
you guys have any questions
about the show, how it's made
or anything about me.
-Doreen, Doreen.
It's time for the sweaters.
Here we go.
Let's do the sweaters.
Here we go, number 10.
Whenever you're ready, Doreen.
Go for it.
Oh! Look at that right there.
♪♪
Beautiful.
Yeah, very nice.
It's a Christmas sweater.
Ah, that is gorgeous.
Look at that.
Claus.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wow!
Want to turn it around?
Let's see it.
Oh, it's a cardigan.
Oh, it's a cardigan!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Uh-oh!
Now let's see who's going home
with tonight's sweater.
Everyone,
look at your seat number.
If I call your number,
come on down.
Quest, can I get a drumroll,
please?
[ Drumroll ]
Who wants a sweater?!
[ Cheers and applause ]
3-1-4!
♪♪
Yeah, yeah, come on!
Yeah, put the bag down!
Get rid of that bag!
Get down here!
♪♪
Oh! Welcome!
Congratulations.
Thank you very much
for being here.
Congratulations.
What is your name?
-Karen Sellers.
-Karen.
Where are you from, Karen?
-Centennial, Colorado.
-Colorado!
It just started to snow
in Colorado.
-No, it happened in Hawaii.
-It's perfect timing.
Can you try on the sweater?
Would you like the try it on?
-Yes.
-I think we all love it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
This is going to be great.
Karen, it's perfect.
I could already tell.
Doreen, help when you can.
Oh, oh, oh, wow!
Look at this! Come on!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Ohhh!
You're a supermodel.
It looks fantastic!
Thank you so much!
Congratulations to our winner.
Stick around.
We'll be talking to Jonah Hill
after the break.
Come on back, everybody.
You look great!
♪♪